Good morning.
Uh,
so yeah.
Got To the end of Karl Marx today.
Um,
and after,
um,
along the tour we are finally at the marks you are probably the most familiar
with or the kind of marks you have heard the most about.
Uh,
the major am I measure aim.
so far in this course was to shake a little the stereotypes are,
which was in your head about marks to show you that Max was a much more complex
thinker,
uh,
full with contradictions.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
search for truths rather he arrived at through,
that's another question,
but he was desperately searching for it.
So we went around different,
uh,
box of marks.
All right.
Um,
yeah and uh,
the berries,
manuscripts,
the first set them to rather big work,
right?
We saw him as a,
hey galleon the central cancer,
there's still alienation.
I,
he galleon concept than he breaks away.
Right.
He turns into a historical materialist and the German ideology allergy but
does not quite get it yet.
Right.
Too much under the influence of Adam Smith's.
The division of Labor is so important and a private property does not get the
sensuality of the analysis,
what it supposed to have for the theory.
Uh,
then,
uh,
you read the ground I in which he kind of now private property is in the central
place,
but he tries to bring back,
um,
uh,
the idea of um,
alienation and he,
oh,
so,
uh,
considers that in the German ideology he became too deterministic history is
more open than,
uh,
he may have believed.
Um,
and then finally he finishes the book,
at least are forced to,
first of all,
you of the book.
He always wanted to ride the scabby Itar and in the capitol only the first
volume was right,
uh,
was finished by him and it was the only first volume,
what clue what his was ready for publication and came out in 1867.
Um,
he offers a very coherent,
very cogent argument.
It's not a messy text.
Uh,
like the Paris manuscript or the ideology or the grown there is a marsh val.
This is ready to be printed.
And it was ready to be printed for sure.
And this is now his major contribution.
Um,
uh,
the,
the theory of exploitation,
um,
uh,
that is,
undoubtedly Mark's major contribution to social theory better.
It is right or wrong.
This is another question.
Um,
I think,
uh,
that are few people who would accept his theory of exploitation the way how it
was formulated,
but there are still quite a few theorists around here who are attracted to the
idea of exploitation and try to reconceptualize the notion of Elliot
exploitation in one way or another.
And it's also something which is very much entered the public discourse.
You yourself use it or occasional you feel I have been explored,
exploited and it actually has quite a bit to do with what Marx thought about
exploitation.
Then you say this is an exploitative relationship,
right?
So the term is with us.
Um,
okay.
And then,
uh,
of course,
in order to have the theory of,
of exploitation,
and this is necessary for marks to have diet conception of the theory of
classes.
And the test I asked you to read for,
he has a theory of classes,
uh,
is an old decks,
much precedes that theory of exploitation.
Uh,
the communist manifesto.
It's also only a pamphlet that is a political pamphlet.
It's not aimed for as a scholar and the audience,
it does not argue his case in the scholarly Levey as most of the argument is put
for Vod in the Chapter I asked you to read from capital,
right.
But it's,
it has a very important to your ethical insights.
Um,
uh,
in fact,
Domar exists,
does not have the theory of exploitation.
He still comes very close to a mature class to Uri.
But it's interesting though,
the today the identify marks a certain Yvonne of the great,
uh,
tourist who created the idea of class.
The other one is by the way,
Max Faber,
but is also interesting about both of them that they never wrote any coherent
analysis.
What class is well in the communist manifesto,
marks and angles,
right of fair deal about clash,
but they don't have the,
um,
concept Schaller barritas yet to really to do it right.
And by the time he has,
after he finished the first volume of capital,
he actually makes sense then what eventually was published by Ngos as the third
volume of capital.
And here in chapter 52 he said,
now this is time to write my theory of class.
He writes a page and a half and then he abandons it.
It's not going to do it too difficult.
Right?
So it believes to you.
Right.
And the next Dext a test in this course to figure out what the right theory of
classes are and was wrong about it.
Right.
Um,
you know,
the fact that Labor is pretty much in the same bind,
he rides a little more than one and a half page,
but not much more.
We were talking about this and we get outcome to Max Labor,
but classes certainly still do haunt us,
right?
We cannot get to the idea of class out of our hair,
even in the United States.
And the notion is around us though,
there is no other modern society,
which is so free from the idea of class and exploitation as the u s o Fay.
But even in the u s Ofa,
we use Theo dark,
at least a bog during middle class.
So the term is not completely alien from us.
Okay,
so let's jump into this and let's do it this time in a reverse order that I
start with the mature theory,
1867,
and then informed by this theory,
I go back to 1848 they're communist manifesto,
um,
and deal with this.
So,
uh,
the major themes,
um,
uh,
for the lecture today is I want to elaborate on the theory of exploitation in
marks,
um,
uh,
his,
idea of classes in history.
And finally to ask the question,
how many classes are there?
Uh,
March seems to have contradictory answers to this question.
And this is certainly a question which still fascinates people who are studying,
uh,
so sad.
These social stratification or class structure.
Of course the answer is,
seems to be obvious probably to most of you.
Yeah.
In the United States there is one class,
the middle class,
the are all middle class.
That's a typical American answer to this.
But for an analyst,
it's a bit dubious answer if that our classes,
how owners that is only one.
Anyway,
video talking about this ingredient.
So let's smooth through the question of theory of exploitation and Ivy and have
to start this,
uh,
we,
the labor theory of value and to go back to Adam Smith and to see how is
proceeding.
Uh,
then,
um,
I want to make a step further,
a March distinction,
uh,
between commodity production and capitalist mode of production.
This is again,
uh,
taking his point of departure as Adam Smith,
Adam Smith's rd of commercial society and what Marx does,
val that are different type of commercial societies.
One,
he calls the Betty commodity production and the other one capitalist mode of
production.
As we all know,
he never used the term capitalism.
He comes to closest to this concept by using the term capitalist mode of
production.
Neither Smith's nor marks had the concept of capitalism as such.
Uh,
uh,
then,
in order to understand what is unique about the capitalist mode of production,
uh,
we have to understand Marcy theory of Libor power as a commodity.
And IVL explained to you why this is so central to mark.
Serious effects partition and then Marcy theory of class.
Okay.
So that's about it.
And now the labor theory of value,
uh,
the point of departure is,
John Locke and that I'm Smith's right.
As you recall,
uh,
or any John Locke as suggested,
that all value is created by labor or I mean he's a little more cautious.
Uh,
at least 90% of all value is created by labor.
how nervous he comes up with this figure is not very accurate about this.
Not very forced coming,
right?
A social scientists today would be a bit upset vibe.
Do you get this number from right?
I,
he doesn't tell us,
but the bottom line is well taken,
right?
You remember clearly,
Uh,
his wonderful,
uh,
proposition,
um,
uh,
the water in the val belongs to everybody,
but who doubts that those who fetch it's out,
the water,
that water belongs to him or her because it is his or her,
ah,
product,
labor,
product and what is the value of that water?
But you are caddying go VA,
uh,
from the veil of what you did fetch from the val at exactly the amount of labor
you had to put in in order to fetch that clear right and my studio of property
right.
And the Nice Labor theory of value though it's not what God is way by John
Locke,
but soy is by Adam Smith.
And as you recall,
right than Smith's claim set 1.0 value is created by labor.
Uh,
uh,
val about of course,
Adam Smith van,
he comes to explaining the distribution of barrels a day,
takes a step back from this proposition and they discuss that.
Then we discuss Adam Smith.
Let me just remind you what the step back forward.
I had the tension right in,
um,
Adam Smith's was on one hand he claims all value is created by labor and then
it,
when it comes to the question,
but how is thou sort InComm distributed?
He said,
thou it ought to be a distributed between industry factors of production,
right?
Labor,
capital and land.
They ages profit and rents and they have to be a fully distributed and adjust
fee between these three factors of production.
Right.
And I think you'll remember be clarified that this is not a contradiction in
Adam Smith.
He somehow then he's claiming that's all value is created by labor.
He almost has a theory of human nature,
right?
That in the state of nature then that is no private property of land and where
they is,
no accumulation of capital,
that all value is created by labor.
Bob,
this is just in this imagined,
right?
Um,
uh,
um,
natural conditions of existence in all complex societies.
Uh,
private ownership exists and drive it,
uh,
and capital is being accumulated.
And then,
you know,
in order to get production going,
uh,
the capitalist has to rent a,
give a capitol advance capitol to the worker Bee Sal,
the advancement of capital,
the Labor would not work.
And therefore the owner of capital has jewel claim for part of the value of
which is created in the process of production because he took risks right by a
offering capital and it had to supervise the labor process.
And wants to have compensated what it's three staking and uh,
it's super visual and you could not operate without lamb.
He's at the site,
all activities,
neither site.
And if somebody owns that site,
they'll have to be compensated that you are on the site and that his rent,
well this is a little more problematic in Adam Smith's,
you know,
for capital,
he makes a pretty strong case.
You know why it is fair for the capitol.
This stool collect profit for the owner of the land.
He,
they are collecting rent.
That's a little more problematic.
Whether rent is also something adjust in the car and the all have a little
unease,
right?
Then we are talking about rent or then VR talking about fun instance,
rent seeking behavior,
right?
That sounds a bad behavior if somebody is seeking rent,
The reason is simple because of associate in our mind,
rent seeking behavior with monopoly,
right?
Rent seeking behavior comes from monopolistic ownership and we don't
particularly like monopolies,
right?
Evonte competition,
free competition,
right?
Free markets and not mauler police,
Monopolies are bad word.
Anyway,
this is a little bit of a problem,
but nevertheless,
I think is fundamental point in Adam Smith's that that is some fair
distribution,
uh,
income between the three factors of production because they are all necessary,
for,
um,
the,
uh,
for,
the production of a production process.
Uh,
I,
I just suggested that in fact that are still,
uh,
people scholars who are seriously interested,
um,
in,
uh,
in theory of exploitation today,
they usually abandoned the labor theory of value.
I have not met yet and economists or political economist or even a sociologist
or political scientist who still believes in the labor theory of value,
right?
So now,
therefore,
when they tried to construct a theory of exploitation,
it is more around the theory of friends rather than labor theory of value.
Okay.
Then let's move further then that started to figure it out how,
what Marx does do Adam Smith's and how he radicalizes Adam Smith's,
uh,
Mark's does not want to go,
the Adam Smith's young bay.
How to say that is a fear distribution of vows between the three factors of
production.
First of all,
he asked her question,
okay,
what is value?
And he defines value of it.
This very simple equation,
uh,
see his constant capital,
right?
Constant capital,
darn means the capitol,
which is advanced by the capitalist.
In order to make the labor process possible,
uh,
constant capital,
Ken of course,
involve the improvement on the land,
on the site of what you are using for your production process.
Right?
There is a building put up on his side.
The cost of the building.
We will have to be recurrent in the process of production,
right?
And therefore it feels also contribute to the value of the product.
The is very able to capital variable capital on means wages and s is what he
calls surplus.
Uh,
product.
this is uh,
uh,
you,
you produce a product,
you sell it.
Uh,
it is not enough for you in order to be and stay in business if all what you
call act and he turn of the Capitol,
you advanced for the production and the vgs,
but you played to your laborers,
uh,
to complete the process.
If you will do that,
you've would be done,
right?
All smart entrepreneurs want to generate some surplus.
They want to get a little more than they started with it.
Otherwise,
why owners would they be their time on this?
Right?
Why on Earth would they take risks?
Why would they spend their time supervising the process?
Why would they start worrying whether this we're very account or not?
They need a surplus.
So therefore that is the value of the product.
Now,
uh,
and here is [inaudible] some capital is investment and here that is an
agreement,
right fit Adam Smith's,
right?
You have right,
uh,
factors of production.
But Mark's most to be consistent,
consistent in saying that all value is being created by labored.
And he said,
but what is constant capital?
There dos constant cap it talk come from,
he said it is coming from Labor.
It is accumulated labor.
It is Labor which was actually performed before capital accumulation was
appropriated by the capitalists.
And it is being now used as constant capital.
So that is one argument is all capital.
It was at one point and product of labor.
Um,
and that is what is your investment.
So as I shared variable capital,
our wages,
and then that is surplus product,
uh,
and that surplus product we are mark Mark's argue is also,
the outcome of the labor process and the product of the Labor as such.
So mark strasse too shy Ovi from the idea that that is a kind of thin air
distribution,
uh,
between,
capital,
uh,
land and labor.
He said no,
I mean all value is being created,
uh,
by uh,
labor.
So this is his kind of reconstruction of the Labor theory of value and leads us
into the idea of exploitation,
right?
We Will Ivo Labor on this in a minute to try to put more meat on it,
but the essence of exploitation is that what the capital is a real advance,
um,
is actually labor,
which was appropriated from the workers in an earlier cycle of the production.
And then the capitalists will pocket the surplus,
will not give any to the worker.
A worker bee will be satisfied with the wages.
And this is that exploitation comes from,
right?
Yeah.
Exploitation somehow has to do with what the capitalists had to put into the
production process,
right?
Constant capital and variable capital and how much he pocketed after the process
was Ooh over.
So that is no,
nothing fair about this.
In Mark's view,
this is right.
The big difference between social democratic trade unions who wants to keep the
capitalist system going,
they just want to have collective bargaining and negotiation right with the
employers.
So to have a reasonable level of profit to the capitalist and the reasonably
high level of wages for the very curse mark said,
well that is nothing reasonable.
This is a system,
an exploitative system.
Um,
well,
and this is what I said,
the rate of profit,
there'll be the surplus divided by,
uh,
the expenditures.
Okay,
let's move a little further and makes,
and let's have a,
it is important contribution,
but Mark's makes between petty commodity production and capitalist mode of
production,
right?
The trying sort of break up,
um,
uh,
Adam Smith's idea of commercial society or market economy or capitalism,
mark seemed to have a more complex notion.
Now,
he said,
this is petty commodity production and he again offers us a little activation
here.
He said,
um,
Betty Comodo production begins,
surveyed a commodity.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you go to the market place Saudi's commodity for money,
in order to purchase a commodity.
Uh,
this itself is commercial society.
This is commodity production,
but it is not capitalism.
Huh?
Ah,
this is why Mars for instance,
was a bit uncertain.
Um,
and he was rambling about this other hall is the United States in the early 19th
century,
really a capitalist economy.
And he,
he was puzzled by this because the overwhelming majority of Americans were
actually involved in self employment.
It was a highly commercialized society,
a highly developed the market economy,
but there was relatively little private capital accumulation.
Most people over farmers or self employed artisans or merchants.
And what did they do?
They did produce commodities.
You've heard a shoemaker,
you produce the show,
but we're specializing in shoe shoe and you did not bother.
You try to also raise chickens and to have x.
So you needed x.
So you brought shoes on the market,
you sold a shoe for money and then your van to the farmer and you bought egg.
So you could have your scramble that right.
Okay.
That is petty commodity production.
All right.
Um,
and the purpose of production,
this is a very important proposition by Marx is satisfaction of needs,
right?
You are operating,
you are producing stuff because you have certain needs.
What you want to satisfy and the production of some good well in excess of what
you need has the purpose to satisfy other needs.
What you have and money is simply a mediator to make sure that different types
of needs are being properly exchanged on the market place right now works here
is very beyond mark.
So the Paris manuscripts,
right?
Well who try to identify markets and commodity exchange as the shores of
alienation.
That is nothing,
uh,
Eliana,
anything about this assess right
now.
But then he said,
well capitalism is a different ballgame.
We are talking about the capitalist economy.
Then the cycle starts with money.
Uh,
and though,
I mean the chapters,
you have red marks,
tries to discipline himself.
He tries to really behave and to be a scholar,
right?
But he can't resist,
His emotions,
right?
And his values are too strong.
So he said,
your money bag,
talking about the capitalist,
it should not have said so,
right?
They could have done these cool objectively simply to say,
well,
we have a not an economic system in which we have,
right people who accumulated capital and they are entering the marketplace.
And what do they do?
They produce commodities.
Um,
and why do they do so because they want to have more money.
That's it.
And I would say this is Bingo,
right?
I mean,
the comparison between the two is really capturing in a very powerful,
they,
right?
The emergence,
what we understand of capitalist economy,
right?
As distinct simply from a commercial society.
I think this is a very,
very important and very insightful,
very simple,
very precise and very persuasive argument.
Um,
now let me just,
uh,
say a few more words about this.
Why is this?
So,
uh,
why does the capitalists,
the need more money than it started the process and live?
You'll get into a bit later in,
in more,
uh,
details.
Uh,
now that are very good reasons for it.
One reason we already mentioned why should the capitol is butter,
right?
Add advancing capital and taking risks unless it is compensated by more money.
And that's in itself a good enough reason.
But that is an even more important reason.
Be out on a competitive market place in a competitive marketplace.
In a capitalist economy,
which in marks on a bird is the most dynamic economy in human history.
That is improvement in technologies.
The capitalists will create more money because it will have to reinvest this
money in the production process.
It has to improve its technology.
If it will stop the [inaudible],
the competition with Vipe it out.
So the capital is has to collect,
right more money.
Then it started the production process.
Even the most altruistic capitalism has to collect more money at the end of the
process.
Even the capitalist who said,
I'm such a good man all the time doing is to creating jobs for the sport.
Poor people that they can have a decent living and the nice suburban home.
And I don't want anything in exchange for it.
I do it out of altruism.
Okay,
let's imaging are altruistic moneybag right?
Still the poor guy does not have a chance.
It has to collect more money because otherwise next year he vault will not be
around any longer.
He cannot be altruistic any longer because the competition of your vibe him out,
right?
That's the argument.
Okay,
so we'll now here,
I'm smart.
She said this is a big change because now the purpose of production is not
Satish flection of needs.
Uh,
but it is really a generation of profit,
which is inevitable because competition among capitalists now comes the big
puzzle there on earth.
The more money comes from
how,
how is it possible that the capitalists goes out,
uh,
with money,
buys commodities and gets more money?
At the end is the capitol is cheating us,
buys cheap and sell dear.
Uh,
he said,
thou,
this is impossible.
If there would be a capitalist who would buy cheap and sell deer and we'll
pocket a profit this way,
that'd be a reorder.
Who've you say they'll ivo compete and IVL Sally less expensively.
And I've,
you'll sell more and dive.
You create more profit than veal Bush,
right?
These are deficiently high prices down.
That is supply and demand,
which sets the prices.
So the,
the more money cannot come out of cheating,
right?
Uh,
it simply cannot come out simply for circulation.
It somehow has to come out from the production.
Now how can it happen that more money is created?
Now this is where the idea of labor power,
uh,
as a commodity comes here,
but the capital is,
does,
is bias on the market place.
A specific commodity and this specific commodity is labor market and labor
market.
So mark argues is that commodity the only commodity which actually can produce a
higher value when it is consumed,
that eats own value
in every other input that I'd be a raw material,
the amount of labor which was put into that room at the Ariel,
but in our production process,
you consume it.
That is being transferred into the value of the new product.
Uh,
so are you are producing a refrigerator,
you need steel or aluminum to produce it.
The value which was put into the production of steel or aluminum will be carried
over exactly the same amount into uh,
the refrigerator you plug use.
So if cannot create more value,
right?
What can create the only commodity which produces more is labor power as such?
Well,
and this is also important that mark suggests,
therefore,
but the Labor has to sell.
It cannot be labor.
It must be labor power.
Now it's,
you may be talmudist stick stuff,
right?
This stressing words,
but it isn't,
I think there's an important idea.
He said,
he said,
if you would sell labor then,
and it,
if we,
if you,
if a John Locke vase,
right,
right.
And all value is created by the Labor and belongs to the Labor,
then the capitalist would have to cheat you,
write would not be able to sell,
give you the price of your labor,
could not have a surplus value or a profit on their bikes.
Therefore the capitalists will have to buy labor power,
the capacity of work.
And,
and Mark's insist they have to think about a system in which the capitalist
surprise based the proper price,
the exit price,
the market price,
the right market price for labor power.
Uh,
the word good is not cheated.
The Vercher is exploited,
but that's not cheating,
right?
So why,
what is so unique about the labor power,
right?
And let me just emphasize this very,
very important for the chapters.
What you have read that it,
those are all of us EC divalence which have to exchange each other at the,
at the,
at the marketplace.
No cheating though.
The worker is not being cheated.
It gets you a proper pressure.
Claude is labor power.
So what,
what is the price after Labor power?
It's exactly like the price of any other commodity,
the price of its reproduction,
right?
How much labor is necessary to reproduce that,
uh,
a commodity for labor power is a commodity.
The price of the labor power is exactly how much is necessary to reproduce that
labor power.
It involves,
right?
The cost of your housing,
the cost of your living and the extended reproduction of labor power involves
that you have to raise children.
It involves education kept me,
you know,
human capital investment.
This all will have to be compensated for the labor,
but if it is compensated,
then the laborer is compensated for his Labor in capacities,
labor,
power,
the work under the supervision of the capitalists and the capitalists will make
sure that the labor after the cost of the reproduction of labor power are
covered the work and order three or four or five hours under the supervision of
the capitalists and start producing surplus value for the capitalist or profit
for the capitalist.
Right?
That is right.
A stroke of the genius.
Right.
That's the big solution.
But he's offering,
and this is,
this is why I said though,
that is a heavy,
of course,
of course he hates capitalism.
Of course he hates exploitation.
But if you look at the logic of the analysis,
this is pretty cool headed analysis and does not imply value judgments,
right?
It does not imply judgment.
You can go through of this had to say yes,
five.
Sure.
That's,
that's it.
That's how the system works.
He does hate it.
And as I said,
he cannot stop and uh,
expressed as it.
Okay,
let me talk about class.
He's very briefly
and now we are back to uh,
the communist manifesto and the,
there are really a couple of issues here is talking about classes,
uh,
as a tense historical category which in Ebay is contradictory to the argument of
does copy towel.
You start thinking about the bourgeoisie as a new class and there's a
progressive class.
Now let's look at this class is as a trans historical category.
Like this is written almost 20 years before does copy Todd [inaudible] theory of
exportation and he said the history of all behaviors,
the existing societies is the history of class struggle.
And you remember I said this idea is becoming already in the German ideology
where he tries to develop these cold cause on mechanism and I teach explains
evolution in history and this is class struggle all along,
right?
The struggle of the surface.
Again,
the slaves against the slave owners,
the surfs against their landlord,
and finally it will be the struggle of the proletariat against the bourgeoisie.
That's the idea,
right?
And this is being used,
you know,
story historical day.
The trouble is that this is obviously wrong,
it's wrong in terms of Mark's own theory of exploitation and the Intro,
it is also empirical.
You're wrong statement.
All right?
Why is wrong in terms of marks?
Because it doesn't fit the theory of exploitation.
If exploitation is unique for a capitalist mode of production reasonably,
you can talk only about classes in a capitalist mode of production where the
labor power is free in the dual sense of the term,
legally free and freed from the means of production,
therefore has to sell his labor power,
right?
If this does not does not exist,
you should not use the term of classes.
So this is a contradiction in Mark's own analysis,
and of course it is empirically wrong because that's true.
There were a class struggles in history,
but vas antiquity,
overthrown by the revote of slave owners.
I gained the slaves.
No,
it wasn't as we have learned from marks if fell because it was invaded by
Germanic tribes did in the south,
uh,
slavery and that,
because the slave level,
did I gains a slaveholder save wondered?
No,
because capital is from their noise,
right.
Initiated that I ever wore at games the south.
Right.
Uh,
did the proletariat ever revolt to overthrow the bourgeoisie naturally Yali in
countries where we are talking about proletarian revolutions that were hardly
any proletarians,
how many claims are county answerer that in China,
1949,
obviously an overwhelmingly present economy,
right?
Those were peasant masses would demanded lands who carried out good evolution
under the leadership of Mount set tone.
Russia not much.
Not much different in 1917.
So it's simply not true.
It's also not true that the trustees of ritual or subordinated earlier,
we will become the new dominant classes.
I mean,
the slaves did not became the landlords.
The service did not become the grand bourgeoisie and the proletariat circling it
did not become a dominant class in China or in the Soviet Union.
Right.
This is all wrong,
right?
Eh,
but the argument is,
uh,
you know,
still interesting.
Then most importantly,
write the bourgeoisie.
He sat is Rhea Leah in your class.
And probably arguably the first three are class the landlords for not a class
because they were not constituted in economic terms,
ever constituted legally,
right?
And by customs rather than simply on market exchange and market competition.
Um,
and he also said,
well,
these bourgeoisie was an extremely revolutionary force,
right?
Um,
and it actually transformed the whole society.
And here I think that is even in the communist manifesto,
he contradicts himself.
He said,
well,
you know what it did,
it transformed occupations,
which we are based on honor before into class positions,
right?
It converted the position of a doctor or a lawyer or a priest enter kind of
casts like position,
do their power to additional,
it was based on honor.
They were honorable positions.
Now they become,
uh,
positions for which an income is being paid.
Alright.
And then he writes,
it's very important to appreciate that mark sees that the bourgeoisie did play
an extremely important too aggressive role in history,
but he's not on,
he hates the gods of the bourgeoisie for sure,
but he appreciates the contribution of the bourgeoisie for the development of
modern society.
Right?
He said,
you're the bourgeoisie cannot exist.
Cows Dunkley revolutionizing the instruments of production,
right?
In scarce 100 years has created more massive and more colossal,
productive forces.
Then we have all preceding generations together.
Well,
sounds like somebody who loves capitalism,
right?
He of course he doesn't because he thinks it will eventually destroyed stuff.
Now the last issue is about how many classes and they all,
what follows from the logic for,
uh,
the scabby towel and,
I think it is also,
uh,
the,
point,
uh,
of Marx in the communist manifesto that our two classes,
the bourgeoisie and the proletariat,
right?
Uh,
the money bags and their workers and the workers are exploited by the money
bags.
And that's the reason for cross juggle.
And that's what eventually revealed lead to revolution.
But my goodness,
where are the middle classes?
Um,
uh,
that were not all that many proletarians in 1867,
there was no society except,
uh,
industrialized Soviet Union and the majority of the population was industrial
worker,
but no ruling class.
David would export it at school.
Don't worry about it,
but the very majority,
but it never happened in western societies.
We never reached that point.
And then of course the industrial working class has been declining now properly
speaking,
industrial working class in the United States,
it's probably not more than 15% of the population.
So where is the middle class?
So,
uh,
well I don't have much time.
Let's rush through all of this.
Uh,
well he said that is,
you know,
these elemental confrontation between the bourgeoisie and the proletariat there
he does not have the theory of exploitation and he cannot explain it.
Fly To Vale in,
you can do it by now.
Armed with dust copy tab,
right.
This is a contradiction because you know,
the proletariat has no choice but to sell is labor power and be exploited.
And this is of course,
an irreconcilable contradiction.
And what about the middle class?
Well,
Mark said,
yeah,
all he,
he is,
uh,
of course even in a political family flat.
He is a good enough scientist,
social scientist that he will say no,
I that isn't only middle class.
He knows that he's a middle class,
that most people do not belong to the bourgeoisie and the proletariat in 1848.
And as I've said,
they never did,
but he said,
well,
but look at it historically a what we call middle class is disappearing.
Look at all peasants and small artisans and small merchants.
They've it all disappear and they'd all have to either very few of them will
become big capitalists and the overwhelming majority of them will become working
very curse.
Now how this is not without insights,
right?
For about a hundred years,
uh,
after,
the uh,
communist manifesto,
the tent was going in this direction,
right?
Self employment for shaking and the wage labor was increasing,
right in league days,
right in the mid 19th century,
70 to 90% of the population was working in agriculture cell phone and was self
employed in other businesses are today in the United States.
The agriculture population,
I don't know exactly their most current figure is somewhere between one to 2%.
Right.
Uh,
and self employment has been substantially reduced for a very long time.
But things happen what marsh did not foresee.
Right.
And what he did not foresee,
uh,
were uh,
and I probably view alleviate here.
There are two things.
What he did not really foresee,
uh,
one that actually these trans churn that that is no more reduction of self
employment.
In fact,
that is some increase of self employment.
It varies from countries to countries in Japan.
Big Way.
Right.
And Are you not to say it song improvement in self employment,
but self employment is stubborn.
It assistant,
right?
You don't have supermarkets but he,
all of us do have your corner delis shops and they don't seem to be
disappearing.
Right.
I even take my shoes to a shoemaker.
Have to fix them,
right?
And so,
I mean,
I do not throw my shoes out.
I go to a shoemaker then fix it for $25 for me and I don't get shoot for 150
bucks bucks.
Right?
So I mean that is mass production has its limits,
right?
It's a quality production right by artisans.
And we want that quality code.
And the more important argument,
in fact,
you know,
Maurice conceptualized wage laborers as physical labors,
physical laborers,
as I pointed out,
manual laborers,
at least in advanced countries,
is this minority of the society in the globe.
That's different,
right?
Because manufacturing and industrial activity was kind of decentralizing the
world into the third world body in the United States and in continental Europe.
It's a tiny minority,
but there is a baby new middle class and these new middle class are those white
collar workers,
right?
Most of you will become and what I am,
I'm not white like the color.
I love this story.
You know,
that means in my sense,
I hardly do any work,
right?
What kind of value do I create?
Right?
What does it mean?
I am exploitive.
I don't think Rick Levine really exploits me and my Amex Spool Tor.
No,
I don't think I explored Yo guys.
Or do you explore to me because I have to say up until midnight to grade your
assignments.
No,
it's not reality.
I actually obey occasionally have fun reading your assignments.
Right?
So we have a new middle class and I had to be simply doesn't outfit the analysis
and where the notion of exploitation loses its inside.
Okay.
I leave it here.
Thank you.